there's certain brain circuits that we
share with all mammals and those brain
circuits that's our biological
psychological nature they dictate that
children have certain essential needs
what I call irreducible needs needs that
if they're not met they lead to a
distorted development so what are the
irreducible needs of children an
attachment relationship with parents
that's absolutely secure where the child
is just welcomed that you are the person
that we want unconditional you don't
have to be pretty you don't have to be
smart you don't have to be compliant you
don't have to be cute you don't have to
be clever the SEC the second point is
within that relationship the child
shouldn't have to work to make the
relationship work because the
relationship should be unconditional in
a lot of homes parents love their kids
it's not a question of do they love them
but if the parents are having stresses
and problems the child will very often
take on the responsibility of trying to
make it better by fitting in by being
nice by being compliant by suppressing
their own feelings this is typical in
homes where there's alcoholism by the
way a child will work to make the
relationship work with the parent